Cause if you're going to blame people
for all the Shit you've been her blaming
them for all the good too.
If you're going to give them credit for
everything that's fucked up,
even credit for everything,
that's great
because life is not so simple at black
and white.
My mother beat the shit out of me.
She loved me.
She was freaked out.
I was going to leave.
I was a source of everything.
I blamed her for all the beauty in my
life.
I blame her,
but I have one have in my life because I
cherished my wife cause I know what the
opposite is.
I blame her for the capacity to feel and
care.
I blame with my insatiable hunger to end
suffering for any of you,
but I can't
because I suffered a ton.
If you'd been the mother I had wanted,
I would not be the man I'm proud to be.
If we can realize that life is always
happening for us,
not to us.
Game over all the pain and suffering
disappeared.
You know any success program that I've
ever had the good fortune to go through,
whether it be a good book,
a good set of tapes,
a good seminar.
Almost every single one talks about the
power of goal setting.
Why?
Because it's a fundamental key to all
lifelong success plans you could
possibly imagine.
The challenge of course is we hear it so
often,
we tend to take it just a little bit for
granted,
don't we?
I mean,
you get yourself in a point where you've
heard it so often.
You're going,
please don't talk about goal setting and
I know all about it.
Yes,
I should make sure my goals are stated
in the positive.
Yes,
I should write them down.
You know I didn't know all that stuff.
Come on,
but you know what?
You gotta be careful not to get caught
in that trap called the law of
familiarity.
You know where he gets so used to it,
you begin to take it just a little bit
for granted because fundamentals have to
be practiced daily.
Hey,
think about the greatest coaches that
you can think of and sports history,
names that come up for me or it names
like Vince Lombardi for example,
or John Wooden.
What were they known most for teaching
fundamentals to people that were already
the best at what they do?
I mean,
think about it.
John Wooden would take a basketball
player.
A kid was the best in the world at what
he does virtually,
at least for his age group,
and he can make a shot from virtually
anywhere and you go,
that's really cute kid.
Get over here and I want you to shoot
400 free throws and gets this.
I can do that.
He said,
yeah,
well let's see you do it or come up here
and I want to see you shoot 500 bank
shots from five feet.
While I can do that again would say,
it goes,
yeah,
I know you can do it and you're going to
do it every day this many times so that
you do it and the key clutch moments.
You've got to practice fundamentals
every day.
He went 11 consecutive national
championships.
Unlike any team in history,
that's the power of fundamentals.
So anytime I do a workshop,
anytime I try and do tapes,
usually I put a goal setting workshop in
there and some of them have some
similarities.
If you've done one with me before,
he has a chance to do it again and do it
even more effectively.
And variably when I hear people say
something like,
well,
teach me something new.
I know they aren't into mastery because
repetition again is the mother of skill.
You've heard me say that over and over
again.
It's because if you want to master
anything,
you've got to do it over and over and
over again.
And every time I do a goal setting
workshop myself,
I obviously make new distinctions.
I set up some new goals they change.
So don't take it for granted and say,
well,
these two tapes are on goals and they're
short and they're simple and I can do
that some other time.
I already know my goals.
Don't get caught in that hook.
The bottom line is do the exercises.
If you're setting goals brand new and
fresh,
and for most people they don't have a
clearly defined set of goals.
Anyway.
Again,
you know,
I'm now taking taekwondo and I had the
good fortunate of training with the
grand master of taekwondo and the United
States.
His name is grandmaster June Reed,
and the interesting thing about jewelry
as a master,
as he taught me something,
you taught me to go from the frame of
mastering simple things over and over
again,
everything he teaches to become a black
belt breaks,
Bam has seven simple moves.
Isn't that interesting?
Now what's interesting is he says that
most people never make it to black belt
because they kept coming in and say,
show me something new.
He said,
none of them.
You have to master the fundamentals,
and if you do those and you do them over
and over again,
you'll be a black belt easily and
consistently.
So don't get caught in those traps.
Breakthrough the bonds of your past and
look at
world and a whole new way where you
understand fundamentals must be
practiced daily and you'll do whatever
it takes.
You're not bored by fundamentals.
You get excited about doing the daily
things that create the ongoing level of
happiness and joy you want for a
lifetime.
Now,
let's take a quick look.
What is the power of goals?
Why do we talk about him so much?
Why do we want need to use them?
Why are they important?
Answer with goals.
We create the future and advance.
We create our destiny.
We shape our lives.
Hey,
we all have goals,
whether we know it or not.
The problem is some people have really
lousy goals and whatever your goals are,
they're affecting you.
Maybe your goals are to get through this
day.
Maybe the goal is or how to pay the
lousy bills.
The problem with goals like Vat is they
don't exactly inspire you and get you to
jump out of bed early in the morning
saying,
I can't wait to go out today and pay my
lousy bills.
Rarely does that really create emotion
and drive inside of you.
Goals can create the power to make us
grow and expand and develop our success,
but we've got to have something out
there that's compelling enough to draws
forth,
done properly and specifically they
transform our lives.
One of my best and favorite examples is
a study that was done in 1953 at Yale
University.
What they did,
there was an intensive study where they
interviewed the graduating class just
before they left school and they asked
them a whole series of questions.
But the one that was most interesting
for me was they asked him,
how many of you have a clear,
specific set of goals with a written
plan for their achievement?
Well,
interestingly enough,
as you might guess,
less than 3% how to set of written goals
with the plan.
20 years later in 1973 they
went back and interviewed the surviving
class members of the class of 53 and
they interviewed these people to find
out what were their lives like.
Well,
the interesting thing was the 3% that
had written goals that specifically at a
plan for their attainment appeared to be
happier,
more well adjusted,
more excited about their life as a
whole,
but see,
those things are subjective.
The one thing that's very measurable is
this.
The group of people who had written
goals were worth more in financial terms
than the entire other 97% that didn't
have goals combined.
Think about that.
That's the power of goal setting.
I can tell you in my own life,
it has transformed me that you can know
all the techniques of how to condition
yourself to succeed,
but if you don't know why you're doing
it,
if you don't know what it is you're
moving towards,
then it's rare that you're going to get
the most out of yourself.
Years ago,
I had the unique good fortune.
As I began to study some of these
technologies for optimum performance,
I was invited to go to Russia and I
spent over there approximately two
weeks.
During that time,
I got a chance to explore many aspects
of Russia.
We've got to go to the universities that
got to chance to meet with some of the
people who were involved in optimum
performance technologies and in the
process of doing that,
I found myself on one stretch where I
was on the Trans Siberian railway.
Where's going literally from Moscow all
the way to Siberia and then back to
Leningrad again.
We're talking about
about a large stretch of land and a lot
of time to just think.
During that time I was just starting to
develop some my personal power.
I really hadn't created my life the way
I wanted it,
but I felt like there was some
possibilities out there for me.
I was still living in my 400 square foot
bachelor apartment.
I was still overweight.
I was still in a position where I really
didn't have my life where I wanted it in
terms of my relationships.
But on that trip for two and a half
days,
all I did was set goals and then for
another two or three days,
all I did was design plans and how it's
going to achieve them.
And I set goals that were well beyond my
present ability or skill.
I had no idea how I was going to make
them happen and that's important.
But I operated from a principle that's
talked about and every religion known to
man.
So regardless of what you believe
religiously or spiritually,
it's a common law and that is the power
of absolute total belief and faith.
I operated from the frame that if I
could get inspired enough,
if I found a goal that it was exciting
enough for me,
I would figure out how to make it
happen.
Even though right now it might seem
impossible.
I would pull it off and I laid out goals
for my life in virtually every area,
personally,
emotionally,
socially,
spiritually,
physically,
financially,
and I chunk down what do I want my life
ultimately and what do I want right now
and a lot of areas.
I thought,
well,
I can make it happen.
I figured I can get control of my
emotions and so I set goals about how I
want it to be,
how I wanted to communicate,
how much joy I wanted to have,
how much passion,
how I would live every single day,
the kind of person I wanted to be as a
human being.
I described my relationships.
I described the woman of my dreams in
detail.
I took six pages to describe exactly the
kind of person,
mentally,
emotionally,
socially,
and spiritually I want in my life and
physically describe her in detail in
addition to describing how I wanted my
kids to be.
I described everything.
Now he might say,
well,
Gosh,
you know,
you're really creating a lot of
limitations.
I set goals and I look at them and then
I review them and see if they still make
sense to me,
but I did it in detail.
I also did it in the area of finances
and I said some pretty absurd goals.
I decided I want to make a quarter of $1
million a year in personal income.
At the time I was making less than
$3,000 a month.
3000 was a good month.
Guess what happened?
I came back.
I laid out this plan.
In fact,
I did the plan on the back of a map,
but I bought them Russia have it to this
day where I broke down the whole thing.
I show it oftentimes to people in my
seminars so they get an idea where I was
and what I actually created.
Just by designing the roadmaps necessary
for success.
I came back and began to implement it.
A lot of my plans,
I have to tell you,
it did not work out,
but I achieved over 80% of my goals and
less than 12 months.
I mean massive change.
I went well beyond anything I dreamed
of.
I changed myself physically.
I lost all the weight.
I changed myself emotionally and develop
the confidence that was necessary.
I changed myself and my relationships
massively.
I attracted the,
one of my dreams,
I'm married,
or about a year after that I had decided
I wanted to have four kids.
I got three instantly.
What a deal.
I was on a roll.
I took myself from totally broke
financially to over a million dollar net
worth and lasts than 12 months.
You're talking about massive change.
My life changed in every level.
I mean,
I can tell you how much my confidence
changed,
but you know,
you might go,
oh,
big deal.
But it did my level of confidence,
my level of faith,
my ability to create rapport changed
radically.
I mean,
and I also said finger goals besides my
personal development goals because I'd
felt confident that I could probably
accomplish some of the development
within myself,
but I felt like I can control that.
I can't control the outside world or my
economics or the ability to get things.
That was my hang up at the time.
I set goals for things like I was going
to have a limousine,
a stretch limousine.
I mean,
how absurd.
I had a car that was breaking down
continuously at a stretch limousine
within six months.
I mean,
I'm talking about massive,
massive change.
Let me,
you can't imagine the kind of miracles
that happen.
I know this sounds fluffy and bizarre,
but it really works.
I remember when first time I went to
Fiji,
and this is my favorite place in the
world,
I thought,
you know,
I've been everywhere.
I've been to meet most of the major
countries in the world.
This is the most beautiful,
amazing land I've ever been to.
You know,
I got to own a piece of property.
I'm this specific island,
you know,
I never would have thought in a million
years.
The two years later after setting that
goal,
I don't an island,
you know,
aren't that owned the resort namaly and
it's one of the top three resorts in
Fiji now.
I go there four times a year with 20 of
my best friends and we all have a blast
and we set our goals there.
We,
we look at our lives and balance it and
have fun.
I mean it's amazing,
but there's just,
if you were to try to tell me that two
years earlier,
I would have said,
you are absolutely insane.
You're nuts.
There's just no way.
I mean,
you know,
get real and I'm here to tell you don't
get real,
get intelligent because what's real to
you today is based on your past,
based on your past experiences.
And if you limit your future based on
your passion are going to go anywhere.
You got to get the goals that are big
enough to drive you to excite you.
So don't stop and go,
how do I do it?
That's not the first step.
The first step is get it down.
And if you do that,
you can create your island,
your paradise,
whether that be something emotional
inside of you.
You want to create like a character
change or,
or a behavior or habit or whether that's
a business you want to start or whether
that's some kind of money you want to
earn or something you want to do for
your children.
And I'm telling you it can happen.
The magic that you've heard about and
dreamed about is real and it starts with
a simplistic process of taking these
generalized impulses of desire and
starting to define them with more
precision.
This is the power of goal setting and we
don't understand totally how it works.
There's something beyond just what we
understand.
If we're writing something down,
something happens.
You become a creator when you write down
goals and you get clear as to absolutely
while you make them happen.
And by the way,
that's the key that we're going to touch
on here in detail.
We've got to make sure that you not only
set goals,
but you get absolutely clear why you
want them,
because there's a fundamental key to
goal setting that changed my life and
that is,
this purpose is stronger than outcome.
What do I mean?
Well,
I think that the purpose of goals is not
so you get things the purpose of any
goal,
the real reason to set goals is what
they will make of you as a person.
Hey,
look at the end of your life,
all the things that you accumulate are
not going to make you happy at the end
of your life.
All you're going to have is who you
become as a person,
the moment you've created in your life
that you'll never forget.
So some people in life,
they go out and set goals and they do it
blindly.
They say,
these are all things that I want to have
in my life and I focus,
let's say on things.
And there's nothing wrong with focusing
on things.
I want you to have as many things as you
want.
That's part of life too.
That's part of the manifestation process
of creating results.
But if all you do is focus on getting
things,
it may cost you some people in their
desire to get things,
have given up their own integrity of who
they want to be,
of what they want to create in their
life.
And you gotta be careful of that.
You got to make sure when you set a
goal,
you know why you're doing it.
Hey,
you might work real hard,
for example,
to do something.
I a thing oriented,
let's say you want to make $1 million
but see $1 million only motivates you so
much.
Becoming the kind of person who is able
to manifest total abundance financially
and physically for themselves and the
people around them.
That's rather exciting.
Having the freedom that you think the
money we'll give you or having the
ability to give or having the ability to
do things that you think that money will
give you are having more time.
That will motivate you a lot more than
just the money.
Does that make sense?
The problem was setting goals is one.
Most people take them for granted,
they don't do it seriously and they
don't do it consistently.
They do it once a year and I do it at
New Year's.
They were run under the New Year
Syndrome.
They set a goal and they don't even look
at it until a year later and they go,
whoops,
I kinda screwed up.
And they set a new one so they have no
power.
Secondly,
they don't realize the power of goals.
They take it lightly,
you know,
they go,
well,
you know?
Yeah,
I got these goals,
but they don't make sure that they get
it inside their head where it's
absolutely real for them.
They don't realize that when they set a
goal,
they're now creating something in life.
And finally,
the biggest challenge I think,
is that these people don't know why
they're going for their goals.
So the object,
the goal itself,
and again,
through the asset for a while.
And yeah,
again,
why is different for everyone?
But you got to find out the reasons I
believe this reasons come first,
answers come second.
If you get a big enough reasons to do
something to accomplish something,
you can figure out how to do it.
But if all you do is set up a goal and
say,
oh Gosh,
how am I going to about it?
You're not going to be inspired enough.
It's not going to be compelling enough
for you to really create longterm
results.
Every great success I know has figured
out the why behind their goals and
that's their power.
So in our process on the next tape
tomorrow,
what we do,
the goal setting workshop itself,
we're going to spend a good deal of time
focusing on why do we want these goals
after we've identified them.
And secondly,
how are we going to go about making it
happen?
But that's secondly,
we're going to start from the frame that
we can achieve anything.
As soon as we think of it.
Somebody wants pointed out to me a long
time ago,
that desire in its Latin form means of
the father desire or thought.
That's interesting.
In other words,
anything that I desire,
that thought process has been given to
me and with the ability to have a goal,
I believe instantly comes the ability to
achieve it.
That ability is built within us or we
wouldn't have the desire in the first
place.
So come from that place and watch what
you can do to create a new reality of
success in your life.
Now I've got a question for you.
Do you know why goals really work?
Well?
There are lots of theories,
but I'll tell you what a few of mine
are.
Number one,
I believe that thoughts are things that
whatever we focus on consistently,
we experience in our life.
You and I know that's true from what
we've talked about earlier in this tape
that if I pay attention to one area of
my life and I focused on it,
that's what's going to be real for me.
That's what I'm going to feel.
I also believe that whatever we focus on
consistently,
that our thoughts are things that as you
think so you create,
so your manifest,
so part of goal setting is just by
having that focus and again having a
consistent focus.
You can't just set goals one time and
they never look at them again and really
expect longterm results.
Although,
hey,
that's better than not having any target
at all.
At least your subconscious mind knows a
general direction to move in,
but the power is doing it consistently
reviewing them,
but point number one is I really believe
that if you focus something,
you'll experience it.
Secondly,
when you set a goal,
there's an interesting dynamic that
happens and that is when you set a goal,
basically you're acknowledging to both
your conscious and subconscious minds
that where you are right now is not
where you want to be,
which is you begin to notice the
distinctions between where you want to
be and where you are and as you feel
that distinction,
your brain becomes dissatisfied and part
of what motivates human action is a
sense of dissatisfaction.
I mean,
hey,
when you're totally comfortable and
relaxed,
feeling pleasure,
you're not super motivated and do
whatever it takes to make things happen.
Generally as a generalization.
However,
when we get dissatisfied,
that's what we got some real power back.
I tell most people in life,
one of the biggest traps that most
people fall into is called success.
For a lot of people,
success is a trap because what happens
is when they get successful,
oftentimes they tend to party.
When they fail,
they tend to ponder and our that
pondering.
Sometimes they make some new
distinctions.
Dissatisfaction is a power that you want
to take advantage of,
not something for you to try and hide
yourself out from there is real power
and find some things you want to move
away from.
Because look,
pressure is what creates human behavior,
pressure intention,
our primary drivers of our actions.
I mean,
think about it,
I never ridiculously simple level.
What makes you want to eat?
Is it not a certain level of pressure or
tension?
What does it makes you want to eliminate
during the day?
Pressure or tension you're buying.
It makes you want to get up and take
that action.
What makes you want to make love and be
with somebody?
There's a certain amount of pressure
that creates that feeling.
Learning to manage pressure and tension
in your life is probably one of the
basic fundamental lessons we all must
master if we really want to have a
balanced life where we really feel happy
and successful,
but learning use pressure and goal
setting is absolutely critical with
literally no pressure to go for it.
We have no motivation and so a certain
amount of pressure is generated.
When you clearly define what it is you
want and you see that you aren't there,
it creates a gestalt where your brain
says,
Hey,
I want that.
I'm not satisfied where I am,
and you begin to have that derive.
Don't hide out from it.
Welcome it.
Look at it every single day.
Pressure isn't necessarily negative.
It can be very positive.
Again,
if you look at it as a tool for
influencing yourself to take consistent
action towards your success,
you all know the metaphor,
don't you?
I mean pressures,
how diamonds are created,
they're just rocks a gun under intense
pressure and now the turned into a gym.
You need to use that same metaphor for
yourself and use goals as a way of
pressuring yourself cause see,
I know a lot of people,
when I think about goal setting,
I said,
well,
you know,
I don't want to like commit to somebody
else about this thing because then I'll
feel all this pressure.
That's great.
That is fabulous.
That means you're not going to back out.
I mean,
Hey,
when I decided a year ago,
I was going to work out every single day
I was going to exercise.
I realize the best way to make sure I
kept that commitment was number one,
understand why I was doing it,
not just salmon,
exercise to exercise.
And I realized in order to accomplish
the level of goals that I have in my
life,
I need an abundance of physical energy
vibrancy,
so I have something to communicate with
so I have something that can drive me
without that.
I've ended up running out of emotional
gas while I'm continually driving up
this mountain called success.
So I didn't want to float down running
out of fuel and I decided I'm going to
keep that up every day.
And being physically violent requires a
certain level of exercise.
So I understood why and I linked it to
having better relationships.
I linked it to having more energy for my
kids.
I linked it to how it feel emotionally.
I linked it to my level of physical
vibrancy.
I linked it to my business success.
I linked it to my ability to contribute
to others,
but we had a lot of motivation going on
there.
But in addition,
what I also did is I use pressure and I
went around and on several of my
programs,
specifically on one I do for business
people especially called the power to
influence one for salespeople.
I'm not burger.
I made it really clear that the only way
to succeed was demand more from yourself
and other people would expect and that I
had decided and what absolutely exercise
every day of this year.
I might reevaluate in the future,
but I'd do it this year and I've kept it
and I'm telling it to you do so I have
to commit even more.
I don't have a way to turn back.
Do you follow me?
Use pressure to your advantage.
Use committing to certain people,
to your advantage.
People that will not let you off the
hook.
That's part of the why sometimes you
don't feel like doing anymore and the
only why is hey,
because I don't want to not keep my
word.
That's okay.
Whatever it takes to get you to follow
through and create results.
So this tape today is designed for
primarily only one purpose and that is
to get you clear on the power of goal
setting,
what it can do to change you and the
critical element to success and goals.
And that is creating a strong enough why
and enough pressure to follow through.
One of the ways we can create a strong
enough why,
by the way,
is not just to write down the positive
wise.
In other words,
Gosh,
I want this goal because it'll give me
this and this in my life or I'll be able
to contribute this and that.
But in addition,
I've learned to create some of the quote
unquote negative wise,
something I would never would have done
years ago.
I'd say,
God,
that's been a negative person.
But what I mean specifically is when I
set goals now I not only write down why
I'm absolutely committed to making that
goal a reality,
but I also now write down why am I going
to get this and I do it from the frame
of if I don't achieve this,
what would it cost me?
And I get a list of whys of prices I'd
have to pay not to have the goal.
Cause see what we want to do to get
ourselves to succeed is link pleasure to
getting the goal and pain to not getting
the goal.
That way our brain will be driven to use
all of our resources to make it happen.
Does that make sense to you?
So I know for some of you it may sound
negative to say,
well what would it cost me if it didn't
happen?
But I think if you understand how the
human brain works,
we want to use the carrot and the stick.
Hey we're in charge,
we do this with anything with ourselves
and if we don't like her goals we can
change them at any time.
Part of the power of goal setting is
flexibility,
not just getting stuck.
Cause a years ago you set a goal
reevaluating and saying,
based on where I am and now my wife,
is that still the right goal for me?
Is that the right direction?
I encourage people to set goals no less
than twice a year.
And I have them review their goals in
detail at least once a month and review
their top goals daily.
It is that kind of consistent review
that'll keep you on track and produce
those results that you're committed to.
So right now the purpose again today is
to get you clear and how to unleash this
power.
And part of that power is the power of
why.
Why do you want things on the positive
and the power of being dissatisfied?
So here's your exercise for today and
then tomorrow we're going to actually
unleash you into a goal setting
workshop.
And you might want to review and listen
to the tape again.
So you're inspired when you go to do
that exercise.
Because I want you to really come to
life and know you're about to create
real results.
When you start that workshop today,
they'll pull out your success journal.
And here's your assignment.
What I'd like you to do is I want you to
write down two things.
Number one,
what are some of the areas of your life
you are dissatisfied with?
Now,
I don't want you to feel bad negative
about it,
but just be honest with yourself.
What are some of the areas of your life
that are not enough?
It's not good enough.
It's not well,
you deserve it to be,
if not where you're committed to having
a b.
Take a look at yourself physically,
emotionally,
spiritually,
intellectually,
financially,
and your relationships.
So the question I want you to ask
yourself is,
what's not good in my life?
What am I not satisfied with?
And get inspired as you write it down
because whatever you write down,
you're going to be able to change.
And that's number one.
And make a good list of things you're
dissatisfied with that will create some
pressure inside of you to create some
powerful new goals.
And number two,
write down what kind of beliefs,
what I have to have.
What are a couple of additional beliefs
since we've talked about that earlier,
what are two or three other beliefs that
I would probably need to have in order
to really set goals and achieve them?
What are two or three new beliefs I'd
need the live by in order to really
start achieving my goals?
That's your simple assignment for today.
Just leave today with a focus on getting
big enough wise.
The power of why is the power to achieve
your dreams.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Remember live with passion
I did and what absolutely exercise every
day of this year.
I might reevaluate in the future but I'd
do it this year and I've kept it and I'm
telling it to you do so I have to commit
even more.
I don't have a way to turn back.
Do you follow me?
Use pressure to your advantage.
Use committing to certain people,
to your advantage.
People that will not let you off the
hook.
That's
part of the why.
Sometimes you don't feel like doing it
anymore and the only why his hey cause I
don't want to not keep my word.
That's okay.
Whatever it takes to get you to follow
through and create results.
So this tape today is designed for
primarily only one purpose and that is
to get you clear on the power of goal
setting,
what it can do to change you and the
critical element to success and goals.
And that is creating a strong enough why
and enough pressure to follow through.
One of the ways we can create a strong
enough why,
by the way,
is not just to write down the positive
wise.
In other words,
Gosh,
I want this goal because it'll give me
this and this in my life or I'll be able
to contribute this and that.
But in addition,
I've learned to create some of the quote
unquote negative wise,
something I would never would have done
years ago.
I'd say,
God,
that's been a negative person.
But when I mean specifically is when I
set goals now and only write down why
I'm absolutely committed to making that
goal a reality.
But I also now write down why am I going
to get this?
And I do it from the frame of if I don't
achieve this,
what would it cost me?
And I get a list of whys of prices I'd
have to pay not to have the goal.
Cause see what we want to do to get
ourselves to succeed is link pleasure to
getting the goal and pain to not getting
the goal.
That way our brain will be driven to use
all of our resources to make it happen.
Does that make sense to you?
So I know for some of you it may sound
negative to say,
well what would it cost me if it didn't
happen?
But I think if you understand how the
human brain works,
we want to use the carrot and the stick.
Hey we're in charge,
we can do this with anything with
ourselves and we don't like her goals.
We can change them at anytime.
And part of the power of goal setting is
flexibility,
not just getting stuck.
Cause a years ago you set a goal where
you evaluating the same based on where I
am and now my wife,
is that still the right goal for me?
Is that the right direction?
I encourage people to set goals no less
than twice a year.
And I have them review their goals in
detail at least once a month and review
their top goals daily.
It is that kind of consistent review
that'll keep you on track and produce
those results that you're committed to.
So right now,
the purpose again today is to get you
clear and how to unleash this power.
And part of that power is the power of
why.
Why do you want things on the positive
and the power of being dissatisfied?
So here's your exercise for today and
then tomorrow we're going to actually
unleash you into a goal setting
workshop.
And you might want to review and listen
to this tape again.
So you're inspired when you go to do
that exercise.
Because I want you to really come to
life and know you're about to create
real results.
When you start that workshop today
though,
pull out your success journal and here's
your assignment.
What I'd like you to do is I want you to
write down two things.
Number one,
what are some of the areas of your life
you are dissatisfied with?
Now,
I don't want you to feel bad,
real negative about it,
but just be honest with yourself.
What are some of the areas of your life
that are not enough?
It's not good enough.
It's not what you deserve it to be,
if not where you're committed to having
it be.
Take a look at yourself physically,
emotionally,
spiritually,
intellectually,
financially,
and
your relationships.
So question,
I want you to ask yourself,
is what's not good in my life?
What am I not satisfied with?
And get inspired as you write it down
because whatever you write down,
you're going to be able to change.
And that's number one and make a good
list of things you're dissatisfied with
that will create some pressure inside of
you to create some powerful new goals.
And number two,
write down what kind of beliefs,
what I have to have.
What are a couple of additional beliefs?
Since we've talked about that earlier,
what are two or three other beliefs that
I would probably need to have in order
to really set goals and achieve them?
What are two or three new beliefs I'd
need to live by in order to really start
achieving my goals?
That's your simple assignment for today.
Just leave today with a focus on getting
big enough wise,
the power of why is the power to achieve
your dreams.